قبل ان اجيب على هذا السؤال لدي يعني شيء
مهم لابد ان اشير اليه الشيء الاول ان ان
من الهجره التنظيمات الموجوده في سوريا
القريبه بالقوقاز بشكل عام وهذه
الجمهوريات
لديها مشكله ولابد ان تنتقل الى ساحه قتال
غرفه فيسبوك التي شكلوها واجهتها جبهه
التحرير الشام وردت تفكيكها ومن سمى هم
يريدون الانتقال الى مكان جديد طيب اذا
ايران في المعادله يعني ايران موجوده في
المعادله نحن نعلم ان قياده التنظيم
القاعده الرئيسيه الان سواء سيف العدل
وكان من قبل محمد المصري وغيره من قراءه
التنظيم موجودين في طهران يعني
ويعني وهو يتمتعون بحمايه كبيره جدا من
الدوله الايرانيه منذ فتره طويله وفق
اتفاقيه معروفه في وساق ابو ثبات والموضوع
هذا طرق بحثا بشكل كبير جدا اذا لا مشكله
وايران هي الداعم ولديها دعم مؤ هو كبير
جدا جدا للروس في هذه الحرب اذن لا مشكله
لدى تنظيم القاعده ولا لدي ايران في
التعاون ونقل المقاتلين الى الجبهه الى
الجبهه الاوكرانيه طب اذا هل نجح هذا
الرهان هناك على الناحيه الاخرى نفس
الرهان في الروس الاسلام السياسي نحن نعلم
رئيس الشيشاني يشكل كتابه ايضا وبسم
الاسلام ايضا وراينا فيديوهات قصيره لهذه
المسائل الكل اذن الحشد الديني موجود
الحشد الاسلامي موجود سواء حتى الحركات
هناك حركات الصوفيه او الناحيه الاخرى هي
طيارات اسلام سياسي متشدده في الناحيه
الاوكرانيه الى ان هناك جن ما يسمى بمده
الشام واماره القوقاز الاسلاميه وغيرها من
هذا التنظيمات موجوده وتقابل انا اريد
بشكل مباشر ومحدد استاذ ماهر اليوم ونحن
نتحدث في عام 2023 على بدايه شهر مارس هل
يوجد مجاميع وكتائب بين قوسين جهاديه في
اوكرانيا سؤال مباشر
نعم بكل تاكيد موجوده هناك تقرير الغربيه
تحدثت عن ذلك وهزم منشور في اكثر من موقع
ومنشوره اسماء هذه الكتائب وموجودين
يقاتلوا لم يحققوا نجاحات تذكر كما حققوا
في افغانستان او في بعض المناطق الاخرى في
الصومال وغيرها لكنهم موجودين باعداد
محدوده لو استمرت الحرب بهذا الشكل اتوقع
واعتقد ان اعدادهم هل هم عرب ام من مسلمي
روسيا
لقى الغالبيه الكبرى هي من مسلم روسيا
والجمهوريات اوزباكستان
وبعض منهم كانوا يتبعون منظمه الرائد
الاسلاميه وهي منظمه اخوانيه موجوده في
اوكرانيا او تدير التنظيم الدولي للاخوان
في هذه المنطقه يعني شيشان
يقاتلون شيشان على الجبهتين وكلهم بدعوى
الجهات
نعم هذا ما يحدث الان الشيشانيين يشكلون
كتائب بقياده رئيس الشيشان ويقاتلون
ببساله وشجاعه مع الروس وعلى الناحيه
الاخرى الشيشانيون اخرون يقاتلون في
الجبهه الاوكرانيه باسم الاسلام ايضا
لانهاء الروس والانتقام
يعني عمليه السائر القديمه من روسيا
لاسباب تاريخيه واسباب سياسيه انا انا